>> THANKS.
>> Jesse: TOMORROW JOE BIDEN
WILL GIVE HIS MUCH ANTICIPATED
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS.
ALREADY A PRESIDENCY IN CRISIS.
PUTIN'S AGGRESSIVE LAND GRAB IN
EASTERN EUROPE ALREADY ROCKING
THE STOCK MARKET AND ENERGY
MARKET.
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO, WHAT CAN WE EXPECT IN THIS
PIVOTAL SPEECH?
FOR THAT WE BRING IN THE CO-HOST
OF "AMERICA'S NEWSROOM" AND
CO-HOST OF "THE FIVE" DANA
PERINO.
>> HI.
>> Jesse: DANA PERINO TOMORROW
NIGHT IS GOING TO BE HUMONGOUS.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO BE WATCHING
WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE HIM DOING
WITH UKRAINE CRISIS AND HOW DOES
HE INSERT THAT INTO THE STATE OF
THE UNION WHICH WAS ALREADY A
HIGH WIRE FOR THIS GUY?
>> WELL, I MISSED YOU TODAY ON
"THE FIVE" I'M GLAD I GET TO BE
ON YOUR GREAT SHOW INFORMATIVE
TONIGHT.
HERE'S THE THING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN GOT NEWS TODAY
THAT THE ABC POLL HAS HIM AT 37%
APPROVAL.
THAT IS WHAT HE IS LOOKING AT.
SO IT'S NOT JUST THAT AMERICANS
HAVE AN OPINION ABOUT HIM BUT
THEY HAVE FORMED A JUDGMENT AS
YOU SAY IT WAS A VERY HIGH BAR
FOR HIM TO CLEAR ANYWAY.
I EXPECT THAT YOU WILL SEE SOME
GRACE NOTES, SOME ATTEMPTS AT
UNITY AND HE WILL BE ABLE TO
INTRODUCE, AGAIN, TO AMERICA HIS
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE KENTANJI
BROWN JACKSON WHO HAD A PRETTY
GOOD ROLLOUT THE OTHER DAY.
THAT SAID, JUST IMAGINE YOU AND
YOUR SISTER, JESSE PLAYED
MONOPOLY ON THE WEEKEND.
ALL THE PIECES ON THE BOARD AND
EVERYTHING IS GOING WELL AND
NEIGHBOR KID COMES OVER AND
KICKS THE BOARD OVER.
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN DID TO THE STATE OF THE
UNION SPEECH.
THESE SPEECHES USUALLY TAKE
SEVERAL MONTHS TO PUT TOGETHER
BECAUSE YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
ONE, YOU WANT TO SAY WHAT ARE MY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND TWO WHERE
ARE WE GOING?
I THINK ON THOSE TWO FRONTS IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT.
THERE ARE IN MY OPINION THREE
ELEPHANTS IN THE ROOM.
ONE IS INFLATION AND THAT LEADS
TO ENERGY POLICY AND WE HAVE
SEEN WHAT IT IS LIKE TO HAVE A
EUROPEAN NATION HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE FACT THAT THEIR ENERGY
POLICY HAS MADE THEM SO WEAK IN
THE EYES OF VLADIMIR PUTIN THAT
NOW THEY ARE HAVING TO TAKE
DRASTIC ACTION, HISTORIC ACTION
TO TRY TO RIGHT THAT WRONG.
BIDEN IS GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE
PAYING SO MUCH MORE AT THE PUMP
AND AT THE GROCERY STORE AND FOR
EVERYTHING ELSE.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, I MENTIONED
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
ASIDE FROM THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL, I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE HE
CAN TALK ABOUT WHERE PEOPLE ARE
RISE UP.
CAN'T REALLY TALK ABOUT HEAR
THAT PHRASE TOMORROW NIGHT.
THE THIRD THING IS JESSE ABOUT
"THE FIVE" I SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD NOT WAIT
UNTIL THE STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS TO ANNOUNCE THAT THESE
MASK MANDATES ARE OVER.
THEY DID WAIT.
THOSE HAVE BEEN ANNOUNCED OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS AND ALL
THESE BLUE STATES AND NOW BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND IT IS SO
NAKEDLY TRANSPARENT THAT IT WAS
POLITICAL.
THAT IT WASN'T BACKED BY SCIENCE
AND, BELIEVE ME, I DON'T THINK
THE COVID MOMS OF 2022 ARE GOING
TO FORGET IT.
>> Jesse: IF ONLY HE HAD
LISTENED TO DANA PERINO.
>> Dana: DON'T WE SAY THAT EVE